das wichtigste gut was wir hier in
deutschland produzieren nämlich die
wichtige energiequelle die wir täglich
zu uns nehmen die nahrung die setzen wir
gerade dramatisch aus spiel und wir
haben nun mal auch aufgrund der ukraine
krieges aber auch vorher schon einen
absoluten mangel an ernährung natürlich
gibt es ein verteilungsproblem aber
grundsätzlich hungern die menschen
direkt bei uns vor der haustür in
nordafrika in den maghreb-staaten es
fehlen weizen mengen die kommen aus der
schwarzmeerregion übrigens nicht raus
und die ersten schiffe die ausgelaufen
sind die sind nämlich nicht nach afrika
gefahren sondern sind auch europa
gefahren nach irland frankreich und
großbritannien und wenn wir so weiter
machen sind wir nicht mehr in der lage
dass wir uns tatsächlich hier selbst
ernähren können das ist jetzt schon
faktisch nur bei obst und gemüse haben
wenn selbstversorgungsgrad von weit
unter 30 prozent das will keiner hören
wenn sie mit politik mit der aktuellen
auch reden da wird mit zahlen hantiert
die sind über zwei jahre alt die sind
überhaupt nicht mehr aktuell und damit
wird immer gerechtfertigt oder da kommt
die rechtfertigung dass wir doch alltag
sind sind wir in keinem bereich mehr